blood that was shed
andrew may have been shot in the back
and bled out in his own yard
but this is what i want you to be
comforted in
in the first book of the bible genesis
it says that when cain
wrongfully killed his brother abe that
death didn't shut him up
you better know the book hey god
i re deaf didn't shut him up because the
bible said
that the blood cried from the grave
the blood kept talking and the blood
kept speaking
and the blood kept telling the truth i
want you to be comforted
because that's why there's gonna be
justice because the blood
will never stop speaking the blood is
speaking
because a warrant is not a license to
kill
the blood is speaking because people
that talk about law and order
but they give us unlawful disorder the
blood is speaking
and i know somebody can i sit down and
say this i know somebody
the state killed him his name was jesus
they lied on him he they called him a
wine bible
they called him a friend they called him
a minister society
they said he provoked the authorities
they said he deserved what he got
but when they shed his blood the air
shook
and the ground shook because their power
in the blood they tried to hide
the truth of his life behind the stone
they tried to hide the tapes behind the
stones
just like they're trying to hide the
tents behind the walls of the courthouse
but until the tapes come out the blood
will cry
from the ground i said there's power
in the blood the blood is louder
than a judge's voice there's power
in the blood the
[Applause]
in the world why are people
coming together because there's power
in the blood the blood will sleep
the blood will testify the blood of
everything spoke
the blood the blood of jimmy
jackson spoke the blood that andrew
smoke
george floyd's blood is speaking god of
allegiance blood is speaking
god damn rights blood is speaking
[Music]
one day the blood
will tell the story that power
power power power
[Music]
as we prepare to lead
i want to bring on the state chair
of the naacp brother spearman
will you come and he will
lead us this is not just
national action network or urban league
the naacp
poor people's campaign all of us will
stand together let us hear
i talked to the national president
uh derek johnson and he wanted
to make sure he told you that he stands
with
us at this hour and has the state
president here to speak on the behalf of
their organization
thank you now god bless you heaven smile
thank you dr barba
we really appreciate it to this family
this brown family we simply want you to
know
that the north carolina state conference
of branches is going to be standing with
you
courageously standing with you and if
there's anything that you stand in need
of
please do not fail to let us know pascal
tayden county
is also going to be standing with you
here
in the local area and so we thank god
for you
heaven smile upon you and i want
everybody to know
that we're going to put an end to this
shell game
that reverend al talked about
the protests that go forth
will be peaceful protests
we won't give them a reason to continue
mischaracterizing our loved
one andrew brown jr he was
a human being and his black
life mattered god bless you
[Applause]
as we prepare to recess
let us bring
bishop arthur clark to do the closing
prayer of comfort
as we prepare to lead the family bishop
club
god bless your heart let's just open our
mouth and put our hands together and
give god a great big praise
amen for all he has done all he's doing
and all he's getting ready to do
[Music]
let us pray our gracious and our eternal
father god
in the blessed precious and mighty name
of jesus
god is one more time that we come before
you
lord we pray now for this family we pray
god that you give them strength and
grace and power
god the fortitude that is needed to
undergo their situation
even now god as we stand with them i
pray god that you continually bless
all that have come out today and those
that are supporting around the world
for what is going on we know you are
able god
to do anything but fail and we thank you
right now god for what we believe you're
going to do
even as we are waiting on justice god we
know that you are
god lord that have no time you are
eternal but god we believe you're going
to do it expediently
and now god we pray that you bless these
that are here
those that are abroad continue to
strengthen the family
even as the crowd lord go in their
different areas
we thank you god for your presence
that's going to be with them we say yes
to your will right now
and yes to your way bless as only you
can
and god we're going to give your name
praise we're gonna give your honor and
all of the glory shall be yours in the
matchless name of jesus
and the redeemer the lord shouted amen
and amen
[Applause]
dr horton comes forward reverend drum
right come on and give us
our closing selection and then
dr darius horton will
lead us in our recession
[Music]
[Music]
oh freedom
all
freedom
[Music]
oh freedom
over me
and before i'll
be a slave
i'll be buried
in my grave
and go home
to my lord
and be free
[Music]
oh
freedom over
me
and before
[Music]
my lord and
be free
no more weeping
no more
over
[Music]
and before
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
we've been fighting in these streets
and we're not done yet i want to say to
this family and this community of these
generals of justice
what we already know we always win
we always win we always win
we always win
[Music]
no matter what may come
our way
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no matter what the circumstance
[Applause]
[Music]
circumstances
[Music]
we always win
no
i want you to know and we'll win
we're gonna stand tall together
and we'll win this card
we will fight
[Music]
victoria
you'll stay tall
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
are you ready
[Applause]
[Music]
i want you to get that in your spirits
[Music]
stand up
[Applause]
amen
pastor horton
so
[Music]
hello
[Music]
uh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
hey
[Music]
um
[Music]
hey
[Music]
hey
[Music]
oh
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
time is filled with swift transition
none on earth and move can stand build
your hopes on things
eternal hold to god's unchanging hand
on behalf of the brown family to each
and every one who has traveled from near
and over from afar they would give me
the privilege to say
thank you to pastor sharpton for the
word of god
that has given us hope in hopeless times
they say thank you to bishop barber for
being a light in a dark season of their
life
they say thank you to the attorneys to
all the ministers of the gospel
this fountain of life church this music
ensemble
all those have who have made this
service what it wants today
this family the brown family says thank
you
and to you the family on behalf of my
family and staff
we stand with you in this trying time
i can't wait to take my dress shoes off
and put my sneakers on
and fight for justice for this family
and on today to all of his children we
realize that your hearts are heavy
perhaps your father taught you a bedtime
prayer that says now lay me down to
sleep
i pray the lord my soul to keep and on
today as you go home and as you lay your
head on your pillow
we would like to present to all his
children today including his bonus child
these beautiful pillows which read
[Applause]
we will make a presentation now to his
two oldest children
and we'll make sure each and every one
child gets their first pillow at the
perspective
time family and friends at this time we
will now prepare for the recessional
the family has asked that we will have a
final viewing in the vestibule
we ask that no pictures be taken and you
please respect the family's privacy
no pictures from those in attendance or
the media during this sacred moment
upon the conclusion of the final viewing
the family will gather on the church
front yard
where they will have a dev release
ceremony and then they will prepare
for the re-pass to each and everyone
here today
on behalf of the horton's funeral home
and cremations and the family
we say thank you thank you and thank you
at this time we're going to prepare for
our recessional
we're going to ask the horton's funeral
home saxophonist to give us a selection
and then the choir will take over as we
prepare for the recessional
continue to pray for the family for a
family that prays together
stays together god bless you
[Music]
so
[Music]
bye
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
can i have more attention please we ask
everyone please respect the family
please stay in your area to the funeral
director
has gotten to your area to allow you to
dismiss
please stay here thank you
[Music]
do
beautiful
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hey
[Music]
okay
thank you
[Music]
hey
jesus
[Music]
he cannot
[Music]
[Music]
be
[Music]
[Music]
it's
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
jesus
[Music]
that he is
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
this family
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no matter what you haven't
gone
[Music]
[Music]
no matter what it is oh
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
we put it in your head
oh
one more time
[Music]
[Music]
thank you jesus
thank you jesus yes
praise god praise god
come on
i was born
[Music]
a
[Music]
it's been too
high
[Music]
but i'm afraid to die
[Music]
but i know
[Music]
but it's been a long long long
[Music]
yes it will
[Music]
[Music]
my brothers and my sisters
[Music]
[Applause]
but then he winds up
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but somebody's out there
hold on
but i know
you